Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Marcos ist mein Name.
Ich bin hier als Erster tätig und heute kümmere mich um Sie, wenn das für Sie in Ordnung ist.
Ja, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir, ja.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ich bräuchte erst Ihren persönlichen Daten.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Natalia Cremor.
Ich könnte Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen stabilen.
Ja, K-R-A-R, also A-Umblaut, M-E-R.
Ja, Frau Cremor. Wichtig?
Ja, das ist korrekt, ja.
Wie alt sind Sie denn?
Ich bin 75.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren, Frau Cremor?
4.8.1989.
Ja, 49 Zolli, natürlich.
49.
4.8.1949.
Wie schwer und wie groß Sie sind?
Also in meinem Pass steht 1.68, das stimmt glaube ich immer noch.
Und ich bringe so ungefähr 80 kg auf die Waage.
Ach, 80 kg, sehr gut.
Vielen Dank.
Erzählen Sie mal, Cremor, weshalb Sie sich hierher gekommen?
Ja, ich habe mit einmal solche heftigen Schmerzen,
und zwar auf der linken Seite, so im Rücken hier oben,
und das strahlt bis in das Bein rein,
und das Oberschenkel bis in den Rücken hoch.
Das wird immer schlimmer.
Ich habe ganz große Probleme, wenn ich auf die Toilette muss.
Das tut richtig doll weh.
Ich muss ständig laufen, aber da kommt überhaupt gar nichts.
Da kommen immer nur kleine Mengen.
Aber nach ein paar Minuten habe ich das Gefühl,
ich muss schon wieder gehen.
Ich habe mir das Gefühl, ich habe mich jetzt mit einmal so schwach gefühlt,
dass ich gedacht habe, ich komme direkt hier zu Ihnen ins Krankenhaus.
Sie haben sehr gut gemacht, zu uns zu kommen.
Seit wann leiden Sie unter dieser Schmerze?
Ein bisschen angefangen hat das vor zwei Tagen,
aber da habe ich gedacht,
ich habe immer so ein bisschen Rückenschmerzen.
Da kann das schon mal passieren.
Aber jetzt wurde das immer schlimmer.
Und als es dann eben auch so weht hat,
beim auf die Toilette gehen.
Ja, das ist richtig unangenehm.
Könnten Sie bitte die Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dunkflisch, rückend, stechend?
Ja, es zieht so ganz doll.
Und ja, stechend ist vielleicht schon gut beschrieben.
Aber es sind immer so Wellen, das tut.
Also, als ob sich da irgendwas so zusammen krampft.
Krampfer hat die.
Ja, kann man sagen so.
Es kommt und geht.
Die Schmerzen sind an den Flanken oder rückend Schmerzen?
Da mehr so eine Flanke, das stimmt schon.
Ja, aber auch nur auf der linken Seite, nur auf dieser einen Seite.
Es gibt eine Ausstrahlung in den.
Ja, bis so ein bisschen hoch in den Rücken,
aber auch so in die Leiste und in den linken Oberschenkel rein.
In die linke Oberschenkel.
Haben Sie gegen Ihre Schmerzen etwas eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe, ich habe ja mein Schmerzmedikament zu Hause.
Ich muss sich gerade mal überlegen, wie heißt das denn, das, was Sie haben?
Ebo-Profen, ja, Ebo-Profen, das ist ja, was man eigentlich so immer zu Hause hat,
gegen Schmerzen.
Aber ja, es ist nicht wirklich besser geworden.
Es hat nicht so gut geholfen.
Also, ja, ich habe in der Nacht trotzdem ganz schlecht geschlafen.
Ich verstehe, Ebo-Profen, wie viele Milligramm?
Ich weiß gar nichts, ich glaube 600er sind das.
600er, nur einmal?
Ich habe jetzt nur einmal genommen, aber das hat dann ja auch gar nicht viel gebracht.
Was mir so ein bisschen geholfen hat, ich habe mich dann mit der Wärmflasche hingelegt.
Da hatte ich das Gefühl, dass es vielleicht irgendwie so ein bisschen besser ist.
Aber Wärmflasche war auch nicht so…
Ja, ein bisschen, das macht einen halt immer so ein bisschen, dass man sich wärmer fühlt
und dass man denkt, das ist ein bisschen besser.
Ein bisschen, ich verstehe.
Stellen Sie sich eine Scala vor.
1 ist leichter als 1 bedeutet leichte Schmerzen und 10 bedeutet unerträgliche Schmerzen.
Wo würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen einordnen?
Also, die sind schon sehr weh, kann man nicht gut aushalten.
Ja, vielleicht so, über die Hälfte ist es bestimmt so bei 6 oder 7 vielleicht.
Frau Kremer, könnten Sie Ihren Schmerzen bis Ende unseres Gespräch aushalten
oder soll ich Ihnen einen Schmerzmittel anbieten?
Nein, ich habe jetzt den ganzen Morgen auch ausgehalten
und der Preis, ob die Schmerzmittel helfen, ja, und solange wird unser Gespräch nicht dauern.
Das dauert nicht so lange und das wäre besser für die richtige Diagnose.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, Sie haben Flanken-Schmerzen und Ausstrahlung der Schmerzen
und die Schmerz, haben Sie auch Fieber, Frau Kremer?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber heute Nacht habe ich so ein bisschen geschwitzt
und gefroren gleichzeitig und jetzt würde ich sagen,
ich fühle mich schon auch so ein bisschen heiß, ja.
Aber ich habe gesagt, ich habe gleich dran gedacht zu messen, ja.
Entschuldigung, Sie fühlen sich ein bisschen fieberig, oder?
Ja, ich fühle mich schon ein bisschen heiß, ja.
Ist Ihnen übel, Frau Kremer?
Nein, also so richtig schlimm übel nicht, also wenn man gerade so eine Schmerzwelle kommt,
dann denke ich so, ja, aber ich musste mich jetzt nicht übergeben oder so.
Ja, okay.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, schwindelig ist mir eigentlich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie Blut in Urin gesehen?
Nein, Blut habe ich da nicht gesehen, nein, nein.
Aber was mir aufgefallen ist, dass der Urin, also ja, unangenehm war, also da hat so gestunken
und es war auch ziemlich, es sah so ein bisschen dunkel aus, dunkler als normal.
Ja.
Und Sie gehen sehr häufig auf die Toilette, aber es kommt nur zu wenig.
Ja, ja, und dann tut es immer ganz doll weh, ja.
Ganz weh, ja.
Gehen Sie auch in der Nacht auf die Toilette?
Ja, das muss ich normalerweise auch, aber heute Nacht war es jetzt besonders oft, ja.
Das denke ich sehr unangenehm, das kann ich vollstellen.
Ja, ich habe mich gut geschlafen heute Nacht.
Aber normalerweise schlafen Sie gut, oder?
Ja, also ich bin das ja gewöhnt, dann gehe ich halt zwischendurch einmal oder zweimal in der Nacht raus
und dann krabbel ich wieder ins Bett und dann ist gut.
Normalerweise haben Sie keine Schlafstörung, richtig?
Da muss ich nur eben zur Toilette nachts manchmal und dann kann ich aber gut weiterschlafen.
Ja, gut.
Ich möchte auch einige meine Fragen stellen.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Atemnot?
Nein, nein, diese Rückenschmerzen habe ich nur.
Herzrasen habe ich nicht.
Okay, sehr gut.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein, ich meine, das ist immer so bei 80 Kilo bewegt sich dazu.
Das hat sich nicht geändert.
Okay, sehr gut.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist es sehr gut, aber ja, also gestern und heute hat es mir nicht so gut geschmeckt.
Ich habe gedacht, es ist vielleicht gut, viel zu trinken, aber viel Appetit hatte ich eigentlich nicht.
Trinkt ihr viel Wasser?
Ja, meistens trinke ich Tee.
Tee, viel Tee, ja gut.
Haben Sie umgewollt Urin, Falode?
Ja, manchmal passiert mir das, aber jetzt, also, ja, vielleicht ist mal so ein Tropfchen oder so daneben,
aber ganz schlimm ist es nicht gewesen.
Ich bin nie weit weg von der Toilette.
Ich verstehe, haben Sie schon früh ein ähnliche Symptome gehabt?
Ja, als ich jung war, da hatte ich mal schon mal irgendwie so meine Verblasenentzündung, da kenne ich das ja,
aber jetzt mit diesen Rückenschmerzen, ach, es ist viel schlimmer, ja.
Das ist viel schlimmer, ich verstehe, aber diese Entzündung wird der Holzig nicht häufig, ja?
Nee, nee, das habe ich nicht aufsparen, nein.
Ja, sehr gut.
Frau Kremer, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen zu Ihrer aktuellen Beschwerden?
Nee, das habe ich Ihnen, glaube ich, alles dazu gesagt, ja.
Das Sie mir sagen wollen?
Nee, ich will nicht, was ich Ihnen noch erzählen sollte.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Jetzt möchte ich zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte übergehen.
Gibt es Vorerkrankungen bei Ihnen, zum Beispiel,
der Bluthochdruck, erhöft der Blutvertwerte vielleicht,
oder eine Zuckerkrankheit, eine ähnliche oder geistliche Krankheit?
Nein, also ich habe seit 20 Jahren so ein bisschen, so ein Alterszucker, ja,
aber ja, da nehme ich halt mein Metformin, wo ich so ein bisschen mit zu tun habe,
dass ich ja schon viele Jahre so leicht mal so Asthma habe,
gerade im Winter, wenn es kalt ist oder ja bei so Staubexposition,
dann muss ich dann etwas inhalieren, das muss ich aber nicht ständig nehmen.
Sie inhalieren ständig keine Medikamente?
Nein, nein, nein, das nehme ich nur bei Bedarf.
Bei Bedarf, was nehmen Sie?
Da nehme ich immer Spiriva.
Spiriva, die versuchen, Spiriva dabei zu haben, ja?
Ja, also, ja klar, das habe ich dann schon irgendwo in der Handtasche.
Und Metformin, wie viel Minigrann?
Ja, das sind Tausende, da nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Ja, gut.
Haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Na ja, wieder so in meinem Alter üblich, ist ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck,
da nehme ich Rami Pilm morgens eine Tablette und damit ist es aber eigentlich ganz gut eingestellt.
Sehr gut.
Und wie viel Milligramm?
Oh, ich weiß gar nicht, was steht denn da drauf?
Das ist auch so eine kleine Dosierung, ich glaube, das sind irgendwie 5 Milligramm oder so was.
Sehr gut. Seit wann haben Sie Blutvorrück?
Ja, ungefähr zusammen mit dem Zucker hat man das festgestellt, also so vor 20 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren, ja.
Seitdem nehmen Sie Medikamente ein.
Ja, kann man so sagen, genau.
Rami Pilm, ja, gut.
Das sind alles, ich nehme mal.
Ja, mehr ist nicht, genau.
Frau Kremer, wo denn Sie sich schon einmal operiert?
Ja, also, ja, was man so als Kind hat, ne, Mandeln raus, Blinddarm raus,
ja, das hat man ja zu unserer Zeit alles noch gemacht, ja.
In der Kindheit?
Ja, als ich klein war, ja.
Mandeln und was noch?
Blinddarm ist auch raus.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Ihre gynäkologische Termine regelmäßig wahr?
Ja, also einmal ein Jahr gehe ich schon zu der Krebsvorsorge, ja.
Sehr gut.
Reagieren Sie allergisch auf Medikamente oder haben Sie eine Unverträglichkeit gegenüber Lebensmittel?
Ne, das ist nicht, also wie gesagt, das Einzige ist so bei Kälte,
dass ich mit dem Astband ein bisschen zu tun habe und auch bei Staub da reagiert,
also die Brötchen reagieren da so ein bisschen, aber also sonst habe ich eigentlich keine Allergien.
Mhm, vielleicht Milben rausstoff, Milben.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist das so was, ja.
Und dann kriegen Sie Atemnot, ja.
Ja, so ein bisschen genau, oder so einen Husten reizt vor allem und das verschlechtert sich dann eben zu sehen.
Mhm, okay, gut, aber keine Unverträglichkeit.
Nein, nein.
Ja, das ist gut.
Sie haben einige Medikamente genannt, oder diese Medikamente nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein?
Ja, so wie gesagt, dieses Ibuprofen jetzt wegen Schmerzen, weil ich das eben im Haus hatte,
ja, irgendwas muss man ja immer haben, weil man mal richtig stark das Schmerzen hatte.
Mhm, ich verstehe gut.
Rauchen Sie Frau Kremer?
Ja, das konnte ich mir noch nicht abgewöhnen, ja.
Mhm, schon viele Jahre, ja.
Ich schon seitlich eine junge Frau will.
Wow, okay, darf ich fragen, wie viele aufhand Sie und seit wann?
Ja, ich brauche nicht mehr so viele, da wäre es ein halbes Päckchen, 10 Stück, ja, auch ich wurde schon am Tag.
Seit wann?
Ja, seit ich eine junge Frau war, war ich in der Ausbildung, als ich 25 war, ja.
Mhm, 25, seit 15 Jahren, 50 Jahren, ja.
Ich verstehe.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also ziemlich regelmäßig trinke ich, also im Sommer trinke ich gerne abends ein Bier,
so zum Abendbrot und dann so zum Feierabend.
Und im Winter trinke ich lieber mal so ein Glas Rotwein oder so abends.
Mhm, aber fast jeden Tag nehmen Sie Alkohol?
Ja, kann man so ungefähr sagen, ja.
Okay.
Rotwein.
Mhm.
Eine reine Routinefrage, die ich aus medizinischen Gründen stellen muss,
haben Sie oder hatten Sie Erfahrungen mit den sonstigen Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das gab es bei uns noch nicht,
damit haben wir nichts zu tun.
Ja, nehmen Sie nicht persönlich bitte.
Ja, gibt es in Ihrer Familie kransche Erkrankungen?
Ja, die haben natürlich, ja, im hohen Alter haben die alle etwas gehabt, ja.
Mein Vater hatte auch diesen Alterszucker und ich weiß,
der hatte auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck und der hatte auch mit Rheumarzt zu tun.
Und meine Mutter, ja, die hatte heftige Probleme,
so mit der Herzdurchblutung, die hatte dann einen Herzinfarkt.
Herzinfarkt.
Und ist da dran gestorben, mhm.
Ich weiß, haben Sie Geschwister, sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder und der hat, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck,
aber sonst wüsste ich nicht, dass er mir irgendwas fehlt.
Vielen Dank.
Was machen, ich nehme mal an, dass Sie Rentnerin sind.
Ja, ja, natürlich, klar.
Was haben Sie beruflich gemacht?
Ich war beim Finanzamt tätig als Angestellte.
Finanzamt, mhm.
Ja, das war damals noch viel Schreibarbeit, heute passiert das alles mit dem Computer.
Sie waren beamtin, ja?
Ja, ich war nur Angestellte, ich war nicht beamtit.
Haben Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin schon lange verwidert.
Verwidert.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon groß, ja.
Wir sind alle erwachsen.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Wir waren eine große Familie, wir hatten drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, also von den Alltagskramen, die sind ja auch schon an die 50,
da sind ja auch nicht mehr immer nur gesund, aber irgendwelche schöne Erkrankungen haben die zum Glück nicht.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Wohnen Sie alleine?
Ich lebe alleine, ja.
Alleine.
Gibt es jemanden in der Nähe im Notfall, um sich um sich kümmern kann?
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig, ich könnte bei einer Nachbarin mal nachfragen,
aber eigentlich bin ich schon ziemlich auch nicht selber gestellt.
Okay, vielen Dank Frau Kramer, für die ausführliche Informationen.
Jetzt bin ich fertig mit meinen Fragen, und jetzt haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, also wie geht es denn jetzt weiter?
Woran kann denn das liegen, dass es so heftig wird und das kann man vor allen Dingen dagegen machen?
Frau Kramer, ich werde jetzt Sie körperlich untersuchen,
dann werde ich einige Blut- und Urin-Untersuchungen durchführen.
Und ich werde auch eine Ultraschalluntersuchung durchführen.
Dann, wenn wir alle befunden haben, können wir sprechen, wie es weitergeht.
Ja, das klingt gut.
Erst mal vor allem werde ich ihr Fieber messen.
Vielen Dank, jetzt nehme ich das Katz im Untersuchungsraum.
Ja, dann warte ich da so lange.
Ja, danke.
Das ist kein Timing.
Exakt, ich habe zwei Sekunden übergewiesen.
Gut, möchte ich jemand noch etwas fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie Ausfluss aus der Scheitwürmer?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Und die andere Frage ist, sind Sie vollständig geimpft,
sowohl gegen Kinderkrankheiten als auch gegen Corona?
Ja, gegen Corona bin ich natürlich geimpft.
Das sollen ja alle alten Leute geimpft sein.
Und Kinderkrankheiten, das ist schon sehr lange her.
Aber sonst habe ich also Grippeimpfungen und so etwas, habe ich alles gemacht.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Scheint alles erschöpfend geklärt zu sein?
Können Sie bitte wiederholen, wie strahlende Schmerzen raus?
Wohin die ausstrahlen?
Strahlende Schmerzen, ja.
Strahlende Schmerzen, die sich in den Rücken und in den linken Oberschenkel schenken.
Und auch in die Leichte?
Hatten Sie es schon einmal einiger Bescheid dafür?
Ja, die Patientin hat beschrieben, dass sie schon als junge Frau häufiger Blasenentzündung hatte,
wo sie Schmerzen beim Wasser lassen hatte, aber eben nicht solche Rüttenschmerzen.
Frau Kollegin, brauchen Sie es, oder können Sie weiter machen?
Können Sie als Erstgespräch machen?
Ja, okay.
Ja, von mir aus kann es losgehen.
Ich versuche.
Hallo, schön, Sie zu sehen.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen, falls Sie für mich kurz Zeit hätten.
Ja, natürlich. Will haben Sie den gesehen?
Unsere Patientin heißt Natalia Kremer. Sie ist 75 Jahre alt, 1,68 m groß und 80 kg schwer.
Sie kam heute zu uns wegen seit 2 Tagen bestehender, zunehmender, sichender und stechender, krampfartiger,
mit langen Schmerzen an der linken Seite, mit Anzahlung in den Rücken, in die Beine und in das Oberchenkel.
Den Oberchenkel?
Danke.
Außerdem klappt sie über ein Andrang, Polakizuri, Disury und Zovi-Nykturi.
Die Schmerzen gegen ihre Schmerzen haben Frau Kremer über Profen 600 mg eingenommen und eine warme Fläche auf den Rücken angelegt.
Diese haben nur eine leichte Minderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 6 bis 7 auf der von 10 auf der subjektiven Schmerzgala bewertet.
Die Frage nach Übelkeit, die Frage nach Nausea und Vomitus, so wie in Kontinenz wurde verneint.
Vegetative Anamnese war bis auf einem Schweißalz hyperhydrosis und eine heiße, warme Gefühl unauffällig.
An Vorerkrankungen wurden seit 20 Jahren Diabetes mellitus type 2 und seit 20 Jahren arterielle Hypertonie und seit langem Asthma-Brunchiale angegeben.
Frau Kremer wurde in der Kindheit tonsillektomiert, so wie appendektomiert.
Gynokologische Anamnese war unauffällig.
Aufgrund genannten Vorerkrankungen nehme Frau Emma auf Medikamente ein.
Diese sind mitformen 1.000 mg morgens und abends, Ramipril 5 mg morgens und Ibuprofen 600 mg Beibedarf.
Die Paliersee bei Bedarf Cipriva oder Spray.
Frau Kremer reagiert allergisch auf Haustoffmilben, die Allergie äußert sich mit Düstne und Posten.
Herr Kremer, Herr Kremer, er raucht seit 50 Jahren zehn Zigaretten täglich.
Sie erhört abends Bier oder Rotwein.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Familien an einem Nestig fanden sich bei dem Vater,
Diabetes mellitus, Arterielehypertonie und eine rheumatologische Erkrankung.
Die Mutter sei an myokardialinfarktus gestorben.
Ich habe eine Bruder der an Arterielehypertonie leidet.
Frau Kremer ist ehemalige Finanzamtangestellter.
Sie ist verwidert, habe drei Kinder und wohne alleine.
Angesicht der an einem Nestig Angaben vermute ich in diesem Fall eine Piole Nefritis.
Was könnte das Differenzial diagnostisch sein?
Differenzial diagnostisch kommen Örolitiases und Kohlelytiases.
Kohlesystitis in Betracht.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Diagnostisch würde ich natürlich die Patientinkörperung untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Mit einem Augenmerk auf Palpation, Klopbschmerzen in den Ländern.
Klopbschmerz hat es in ihrer Lage.
Sehr gut, ja.
Außerdem würde ich das Fieber messen.
Ob ein Fieber vorhanden ist, müssen wir das feststellen.
Außerdem würde ich Blutdruck messen, ob es um eine Eurosepsis...
geht.
Wie Teilen wir die Parameter würde ich natürlich kontrollieren.
Ich werde auch Blut abnehmen.
Da würde ich ein großes kleines Blutbild veranlassen.
Entzündungswerte wie z.B. C-Alpe, BCG.
Und vielleicht Prokastalzitonin sollen analysiert werden.
Außerdem Nierenwerte z.B. Kreatinin oder glomerulare Filtrationsrate.
Würde ich auch bestimmen lassen.
Bitte sind auch wichtig.
Wenn ich einen Verdacht auf Eurosepsis habe, würde ich auch ein Blutkultur veranlassen.
Außerdem als Bildgebände...
Was brauchen wir beim Labor außer der Blutuntersuchung?
Ja, und Urindiagnostik natürlich.
Urindiagnostik, Urinkultur und...
Also vorhanden sein von Nitrit, Leukosüt und...
Erdroden.
Erdroden, ja.
Ja, sehr gut.
Gut, jetzt wollen wir eben etwas zu dem Bildgebenden Verfahren sagen.
Eine Nierenultraschall.
Also, wenn ein Aprimonultraschall sehr hilfreich wäre,
können wir unsere Differenzialdiagnose ausschließen.
Mit Hirschaluntersuchung.
Ja, und...
Ja.
Okay, wenn sich das jetzt tatsächlich bestätigt,
was würden Sie dann mit der Patientin machen?
Ich werde...
Sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen,
würde ich den Patientin...
Also, es hängt davon ab, aber vielleicht klatsitionär aufnehmen,
weil der Patientin schon sehr alt ist.
Es gibt einige Kriterien für stationäre Aufnahme.
Ich würde diese Patientin stationär aufnehmen.
Sie sagten ja auch, dass ihr alleinstehend ist, ne?
Ja, das ist stationär aufnehmen.
Ein Schmerztherapie ist indiziert mit Novalgin,
hilft gut oder Paracetamol.
Außerdem würde ich eine Antibiotiktherapie einleiten.
Ja, das kann Ziproflaxa-Sin
oder dritte Generation, Sepholosporin,
kann auslösen.
Genau, und worauf achten Sie noch?
Was noch?
Als konservatives.
Die Patientin so viel trinken?
Darauf wollte ich drauf raus, ja.
Viel Flüssigkeit zuvor ist wichtig, besonders in diesem Alter.
Ja, sehr gut.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Lausensen, wie es der Frau Kramer geht,
dass bei Ihren Untergrundergebnissen rauskommt.
Und dann schauen wir uns die Patientin später zusammen noch an.
Gut, das ist prima.
Ja, ich würde mal sagen,
Sie haben eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht.
Sie waren systematisch.
Sie waren sehr zugewandt.
Der Patientin gegenüber hatten eigentlich keine sprachlichen Probleme.
Die hat sie ja ein bisschen zugetextet, die hat ja viel geredet.
Und Sie haben aber eigentlich gut zugehört und gemerkt,
wo sie schon etwas gesagt hat, was Sie noch gar nicht gefragt haben.
Das haben Sie mit registriert
dann praktisch für sich an richtiger Stelle vermerkt.
Das ist mir positiv aufgefallen.
Und aufgefallen ist mir auch, dass Sie,
wie ich überhaupt keine Fehler gemacht haben, bei Zahlen oder so,
das war alles perfekt.
Ja.
Beim Bericht
fand ich es auch sehr gut,
dass Sie nicht so einen langen Wandvormsatz am Anfang gemacht haben,
sondern erst mal, dann stellte sich wegen
das, was ich prokredienter stechen darf, langen Schmerzen vor.
Und dann haben Sie praktisch ergänzt,
was noch so an zusätzlichen Sachen zu sagen war.
Und da sind Sie auch sehr schön im Bericht
Ihrem Schema gefolgt.
Ja, genauso wie Sie abgefragt haben,
haben Sie die Dinge auch wiedergegeben
und haben das Sprachlicht, weil Sie sich sehr, sehr gut gelöst.
Und auch Ihre Fachbegriffe dann in der,
in der Klarstellung,
da gab es eigentlich nichts dran zu bemängeln.
Ja, schade, schade, dass Sie noch so lange auf Ihren
Punktestermin waren.
Ja, eigentlich wären Sie gut bereit jetzt.
Ja, in Bayern ist es ein bisschen problematisch.
Weil es ist sehr schwierig nach der Patientinvorstellung
fängt, fangen die Fragen an.
Ja, da bohren die nach und die bohren auch
an ganz komischen Stellen nach.
Wenn da, also in der Familie in einem Nese irgendeine
Auffälligkeit ist, dann fangen die mit einmal an,
nach solchen Sachen zu fragen.
Ja, das finde ich aber eigentlich auch nicht so richtig
fair, muss ich sagen, für eine Sprachprüfung,
denn das sind ja eigentlich mehr Kenntnisgeschichten dann.
Aber na gut, die sagen natürlich, ja,
man darf nicht nur in dem einen Bereich jetzt zeigen,
was man an Terminologie zum Beispiel drauf hat,
sondern man muss das eben in allen Bereichen zeigen.
Und insofern mag das vielleicht so eine Erklärung sein
für diese Fach- oder so ein bisschen exotischen Fragen.
Manchmal machen sie ja auch, ich weiß nicht, ob das in Bayern
auch speziell so ist, dass sie dann ganz andere Sachen fragen.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Einweisung und Überweisung?
Ja, und ja, was versteht man unter einer AU?
Ja, und das sind dann so Sachen, wo man denkt,
hey, ist doch eigentlich völlig klar, was ist ein Reha?
Was versteht man darunter?
Dann gibt es Definitionen, die man mehr oder weniger bieten muss.
Ja, aber ich würde mal sagen, so überzeugend,
wie Sie jetzt Ihre ersten beiden Teile abgeliefert haben,
bleibt denen eigentlich nicht mehr viel,
wo Sie jetzt noch dran rumdrehen könnten im dritten Teil.
Wenn da jemand ganz viele Schwächen im ersten oder zweiten Teil zeigt,
dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass Sie dann nochmal nachbohren
im dritten und sagen, ja, Frau Kollegin, haben Sie denn auch?
Und dann wollen die einfach nochmal checken, ob da noch was kommt.
Aber ich glaube, wenn Sie so eine überzeugende Vorstellung bieten,
wie jetzt, müsste das glatt laufen.
Ja, ich hoffe, vielen Dank.
Ich würde mal sagen, das war sehr schön.
Danke.